[Applaudissements]
ce soit on vous présente une enquête qui
est bien loin de tout ce que vous avez
l'habitude de voir à l'émission luc
chartrand on peut pas dire qu'on associe
spontanément le nom de marie victorin à
la sexualité
dites nous comment vous êtes tombé sur
ces lettres là qui sont assez
surprenants écoutez ça fait une
trentaine d'années en 1990 j'avais
découvert l'existence de ces quatre-là à
l'époque où l'université du québec à
montréal négociateurs acquisitions
j'avais eu des copies qui m'avait été
transmises clandestinement et puis qui
était plutôt illisible mais j'avais
quand même pu en faire un compte rendu
d'un magazine d'actualité
par la suite l'université du québec
impose un embargo sur ses lèvres
aujourd'hui mais l'embargo élevé et le
clae l'intérêt de ces lettres la marie
victorin c'est un révolutionnaire dans
tous les domaines il essaie de
transformer le québec il fasse sortir de
ce qu'on appellerait 28 ans la grande
noirceur et bien dans le domaine de la
sexualité comme dans à peu près tous les
domaines c'était vraiment un personnage
d'avant-garde en écoute votre reportage
c'est un précieux trésor d'une jeune
fille de 18 ans c'est ce qui ressemble
plus à une fleur et parlant vous mais
recèle gauvreau jeu puis bien pousser
l'analogie un peu plus loin
n'y at il pas quelque chose de la
structure de la fleur dans la
disposition des organes génitaux
féminins les grandes et petites lèvres
ne suggère tel pan calice et carole
[Musique]
pendant une dizaine d'années le frère
marie-victorin à partager des
confidences étonnante avec une jeune
collaboratrice
elle s'appelait marcel gauvreau s'était
dit d'être sexuellement très explicite
mais elle n'était pas aux français
au contraire
[Musique]
vous faites beaucoup d'honneur je veux
bien me prêter à votre désir tout en
étant toujours un peu effrayé de mon
audace soyons chère fille la preuve
vivante que l'on peut tout voir tout
savoir de lui même nature sans que cette
connaissance soit une foulure sans que
ce contact avec les choses du tout
honteuse nour abbès en rien ils sont
tous les deux bien conscient de se
trouver sur un terrain moralement
glissant il est un religieux et il a
fait voeu de chasteté
elle a 27 ans 22 ans de moins que lui
elle est célibataire les vierges et elle
n'a au début de ces échanges qu une
connaissance approximative de la
sexualité
il s'impose comme son guide pas par son
âge que par son statut de scientifique
et celui d'hommes d'église
elle n'a t'elle pas pas et se présente
comme sa fille au cours de nos
conversations biologique je me suis
parfois arrêté sur le bord de mer d'une
france debout de description craignant
de déflorer votre pensée de dresser une
image obsédante et malsaine mais j'ai
passé outre les bienfaits
plus de 250 pages de ces lettres dorment
depuis un quart de siècle dans la voûte
des archives de l'université du québec à
montréal
signe de leur caractère sulfureux les
archives avait imposé un embargo sur
leurs consultations suite à leur
acquisition dans les années 90 la
correspondance est aujourd'hui
accessible
c'est une contribution fondamentale
l'histoire la sexualité au québec sq ont
eu très peu de documents écrit
l'historien yves gingras spécialiste de
marie-victorin publie aujourd'hui celle
de ces lettres qui sont attribués aux
religieux celle de sa correspondante
marcel gauvreau sont toujours soumises
aux restrictions du droit d'auteur et ne
sont pas publiés cette correspondance là
nous fait voir la difficulté de la
chasteté chez 1up frères des écoles
chrétiennes ou un prêtre en général la
difficulté d'une relation homme femme
il le dit dans ces lettres une relation
de femmes chasse c'est très difficile et
nous on est capable parce qu'on va
sublimer
c'est son terme sublime et l'amour
corporels en amour théorique on redon
est platonique et étudiants semblent la
nature humaine étudiés c'est bien le mot
ce sont des scientifiques et le cadre
strict et rassurant de la science va
leur permettre d'explorer la sexualité
sans se culpabiliser c'est sur cette
prémisse que débutent en 1935 ce qu'ils
appellent entre eux et lettres
biologique
certaines des lettres pour avoir 20
pages dactylographiées
et ça ça vaut entre 1934 et 1944 pendant
dix ans ils sont échanger de façon
régulière
leurs réflexions leurs analyses même
leurs expérimentations dans le cas de
marie victorin sur la sexualité humaine
celle être profondément original ne sont
pas celles de n'importe qui le fondateur
du jardin botanique et d'auteurs de la
flore laurentienne
la première grande oeuvre scientifique
du canada français il est aussi un
puissant réformateurs qui secoue le
québec et son système d'éducation
les canadiens français écrit-il doivent
sortir de leur condition de [ __ ]
blancs en apprenant les sciences les
techniques et le commerce
marie doré et l'est de l'actuelle le
plus visible le plus radical du québec
le rôle de marie victorin comme
précurseur la route sont tranquilles et
très bien exprimé par son étudiant
jacques rousseau qui écrit au début des
années 60 en 1920 on se met et en 1960
on récoltait donc c'est clair et c'est
un chercheur centrale et connaître sa
pensée par des nouvelles est comme celle
là est fondamentale ce sont aussi des
textes d'une richesse indiscutable sur
le plan littéraire marie-victorin décrit
le pénis soja d'oeuvres du grand
ingénieur se présente vous le savez dans
deux états extrêmement différent en
raison de son effectivité
c'est une espèce de baromètre physique
et psychique que l'homme porte toujours
sur lui
les audaces qui le lui céder audace qui
lui permettait de compléter son désir de
connaissance qui est très grand tout en
restant dans les limites de la chasteté
qui est qui était le voeu qu'il avait
fait comme frères des écoles chrétiennes
dès 1906 dans le québec de la première
moitié du 20e siècle une partie
considérable de la jeunesse canadienne
française entre en religion que ce soit
dans la prêtrise ou dans les communautés
de faire route sort ils sont plus de
25000 religieux 1% de la population
c'est un record dans le monde catholique
entré chez les frères des écoles
chrétiennes dès l'âge de 16 ans marie
victorin est confronté aux tourments de
la privation sexuelle comme je sens dans
ma chair l'aiguillon de mes 20 ans et
combien fortement tout au long de son
noviciat la chasteté s'avère pour lui
une renonciation douloureuse qu'ils
confient périodiquement son journal
intime
sa vision de la sexualité est sorti
terrifiante
grâce à dieu j'ai la douce espérance
sinon l'heureuse certitude
d'abord encore la perle de la virginité
cet immense faveur c'est à vous au bon
maître que je la dois à vous seuls qui
avait écarté de mons entier les
charognes du vice la sexualité est
quelque chose qui est assorti à
l'animalité et donc ce qui est noble cdh
à s'élever au dessus
l'historienne louise bienvenue s'est
intéressée à l'éducation religieuse de
cette période en particulier à l'idéal
de chasteté la chasteté et peser d'un
poids assez lourd sur beaucoup
d'individus qui était dans les
communautés religieuses et qui avaient
pris des engagements à demeurer pure
mais qui prenaient souvent ses
engagements l'autre est jeune on a
l'impression que personne ne défroqué
avant les années 60 mais dans
l'entre-deux-guerres on sait qu'ils
avaient à peu près 30 % des garçons des
jeunes hommes qui entrait chez dans les
communautés et qui en sortait
marie victorin et lui a choisi de rester
il est devenu un scientifique et un
universitaire respecté à ses côtés
marcel gourou et bibliothécaires
scientifique est riche aussi au jardin
botanique l'école de l'éveil destinée à
faire naître chez les plus petits le
goût des sciences naturelles confidente
de marie-victorin son âme soeur
dieu par vous a mis sur mon chemin une
de ces femmes capables d'élever un homme
très haut
ici c'est un mythe et avancer dans la
vie et si d'autres religieux étrange
aventure vérité pour marcel il est ni
plus ni moins qu'une idole en voyant ce
film sur les animaux d'afrique
je vous voyais comme tarzan se défendant
vaillamment contre les lions les tigres
et les rhinocéros et qui à la fin gagné
toutes les batailles
toute la carrière de l'ancien gourou et
fait totalement dictée par marc huitorel
à tel point qu'on peut penser que c'est
une domination mais elle ne le vis pas
comme ça elle du contrat qu'elle lui
doit tout et en un sens c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que je serais devenu sans vous
une petite dactylo dans un bureau
quelqu'un la science leur donne la
permission de tout explorer et même de
remettre en question les scrupules
religieux grâce à la biologie il dit le
maximum de désir sexuel arrive je savais
et je serai prêt le vul à sion et donc
il dit ensuite vous voyez le diable n'a
rien à voir là dedans qui fend d'un sexe
et la réflexion d'un religieux et on
n'entend pas soin de lui non et c'est le
côté bien sûr avant gardiste de marie
vitré
même la littérature érotique sert leurs
recherches
comme vous me l'aviez demandé je vous
envoie des caprices du sexe
vous ne direz quel effet physiologique
si effet il ya cette lecture produits en
vous quels effets psychologiques ou s'il
produit
j'avais pensé à vous épargner les
gravures mais à quoi bon
ils demandent aussi à marcel de se
masturber pour lui en faire ensuite la
description au nom de la science bien
sûr vous me demandez à la fin de la page
18 de vous faire l'histoire complète et
analytique de l'orgasme typique
il lui demande effectivement de lui
décrire ce qu'il dit aucun livre ne peut
nous donner une véritable information
sur le sens 6 mai d'une femme qui a un
orgasme et elle lui décrit de façon
précise
votre dissertation sur la répercussion
de caresses ma mère dans la région julve
originale en rapport avec votre
expérience personnelle me frappe par sa
justesse le botaniste n'est jamais très
loin
ici on voit qu'une parle de plantes dans
leur relation avec le sexe et nous dit
d'autres plantes ont encore une odeur
nettement féminine 10 ont nettement
vulvert
on ne perd pas de vue la science
description observations mesure analyse
jusqu'à la chimie des sécrétions
vaginales
c'est un savant et se familiarisent avec
la recherche de points un quart de
siècle avant la pilule il voit même
venir la révolution anticonceptionnelle
et bientôt on aura même des hormones
synthétiques et du d'ailleurs on se
demande qu'est ce que les théologiens
vont en faire
ils devront s'adapter
sous la chape de plantes son époque les
idées de marie victor et son
révolutionnaire la contraception est
alors condamné sans appel la honte dé
grossesse hors mariage conduit chaque
année des milliers d'enfants dits
illégitime dans les orphelinats
c'est un monde extraordinairement
puritains dans les bibliothèques les
livres qui effleure les thèmes sexuels
sont mis sous clé dans une section
baptisée l'enfer des images de nudité et
les définitions sont censurés jusque
dans les pages des dictionnaires la
science a permis à marie victorin de
voir le sexe autrement grâce à la
biologie écrit-il il s'est construit
pour lui même un système moral
le moral en fait si audacieuse qui
serait difficile de l'après chez à tous
il croit que l'église devra tôt ou tard
permettre aux prêtres de se marier
lorsque la chasteté est pour eux une
épreuve insurmontable
la morale catholique lui père est
souvent dépassée propre et son
refoulement
il se montre même conscient du risque
des abus sexuels des religieux sur des
élèves
je connais un religieux de mes amis qui
a conscience d'être partiellement
inverti le contact des élèves est un
danger permanent dont il a pleinement
conscience
il faut que je l'encouragent fréquemment
pour l'empêcher de se désespérer marie
victorin et marcel govou finissent par
en savoir plus sur le 7 que l'immense
majorité de leurs contemporains y est
d'ailleurs un regard lucide et très
critique sur la pauvreté de l'éducation
sexuelle au québec on va jusqu à
commenter sur ce qui se passe dans les
douches des collèges la façon dont
l'éducation sexuelle est faible ray
dispose plus de novices ali communicante
il vient d'avoir une émission
spermatique hanche élèves est cependant
quoi de plus naturel ou ignorance de
crimes commis en tournon signifie toute
la question des menstruations on devient
comme un grand mystère et écrit beaucoup
d'anxiété et lui c'est quelque chose qui
le déplore parce que pour lui la
connaissance et quelque chose à
valoriser et le corps humain doit être
objet de connaissance et non pas
uniquement de prescrit moreau
le temps passe le flirt devient de plus
en plus ouvert
il arrive parfois quand je suis avec
vous que votre robe glisse et découvre
un peu de cul sous dessus du bas
cette vision d'un instant n'est pas
désagréable je ne serai pas un homme
sinon été autrement tant de confidences
et de confessions intimes pros tels les
laisser indéfiniment sur le terrain de
la chasteté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque hiver à partir de 1938 le frère
marie-victorin séjourne à cuba
survivants de la tuberculose
il fuit la froidure hivernale et il
trouve dans cette île des caraïbes
un terrain de choix pour étudier les
plantes tropicales il rejoint sur place
le frère léon un membre de la communauté
des frères des écoles chrétiennes de
cuba ensemble ils feront sept voyages
d'exploration botanique dans l'île notre
victoire était le leader de dirigeants
lyon était le scientifique le docteur
antonio lopes est un des doyens de la
recherche potennec à cuba les ouvrages
scientifiques de victorin et de léon
sont selon lui tout à fait originaux
encore aujourd'hui ces livres ont une
grande importance
je ne connais pas une autre oeuvre comme
100 britannique avec une telle précision
dans la description des dieux où il a
trouvé les plans la flore à des coups
bas
un livre de référence pour tous les
naturalistes du pays rend un hommage aux
québécois plusieurs espèces ont été
nommés en son honneur des frères des
écoles chrétiennes possède à la havane
ce grand collège et selon les règles de
la communauté marie-victorin devrait
normalement est logique quand il y
débarque
cependant et multiplie les prétextes
pour ne pas y aller
ils préfèrent des hôtels comme celui-ci
luxueux victoria qui pourtant je trouve
tout près de la résidence des frères le
thème victoria jusqu'en 1959 était un
bordel de luxe une maison de rendez vous
pour les riches
au cours de ses voyages la soutane
tombent au profit des habits de ville
marie victorin ne perd pas de vue sa
quête secrète il se retrouve dans un
pays où à cette époque la prostitution
est légale sur le prado la grande artère
centrale de la havane
fleury le commerce sexuel rien de ce qui
est humain est interdit à la curiosité
scientifique
c'est en partant de cette conviction
qu'un soir de 1939 mari victor et va se
livrer pour la première fois à 53 ans à
une exploration intime et méthodique du
corps d'une femme
elle se nomme lydia l'organe que je
voulais surtout étudié était le cri
terisse chez lydia les glands est très
petit au moins il m'apparut tél comme
elle me voyait examiné l'organe avec
soin avec une loupe faible elle m'a
demandé ce que j'en pensais pendant que
je manie avec délicatesse le clitoris
lydia entra en orgasme
pour le dire en passant c'est un grand
spectacle de la nature que ce corps de
femme enlevée dans l'extase de l'orgasme
toute la vie rassemblés en un point
une multitude de muscles et des nerfs
normalement inerte son show couilles
comme si chacun devait apporter sa
contribution
kroutov devant lydia marie-victorin d'y
être demeuré chaste il la reverra
plusieurs fois et dans plusieurs voyages
subséquents il s'en fera confidente et
une amie il verra aussi plusieurs autres
prostituées
il en fera de nombreux ici à sa
correspondante marcel gauvreau jamais je
n'oublierai ses heures étrange de ma vie
où je puis étudié la femme sans la vie
lire et sans ma vie lire moi même étudié
en dehors de tout souci est de toute
convention désormais familier des nuits
glauque de la havane
marie victorin est fréquent entre autres
la très jeune mercedes mercedes la
petite mulâtresse écolière supposait
avoir 15 ans réagissait rapidement à la
situation du clitoris
quand je dis à mercedes que pour une
fillette de 15 ans elle avait eu mon
bien escarpé et une toison en brosse
elle me répondit acquis une coups bas
les filles sont précoces marie vitré
pense qu'elle est plus vieille que 15
ans et donc assez curieux mais elle dit
oui mais chez nous se développent plus
rapidement
donc effectivement elle a 15 ans mais
c'est pas un enfant on n'est pas en 1975
on n'est pas en bus mais l'hôte en 1935
1940 et il faut rappeler qu'à l'époque
l'âge du consentement et large de la
forme d'adieu ses 14 ans
la cub à marie victoret découvre une
société où la religion et la sexualité
semblent faire bon ménage dans la
chambre de lydia il s'étonne de la
présence d'image st c'est le pays où les
filles de joie pour tout coup la
médaille de notre dame de la charité et
ne trouve pas déplacé de la baiser
devant clients
mais cette dévotion de lydia peut cacher
un sens qui lui échappe
sept médailles pieuses elle peut être le
reflet de ses croyances dans une
religion qui est pas la religion
catholique
le critique littéraire jean fugère est
un passionné de culture cubaine
c'est une société dit il où le
catholicisme n'est souvent qu'une façade
qui cache les religions africaines la
vierge de la caridad delcourt brees pour
laquelle il y avait une vénération
particulière du maire elle est associée
par les afro cubains à autre chose autre
choc est une déesse de la sexualité de
la séduction de la féminité et la
mentalité de la religion afro cubaine
permet cette coexistence et cette
juxtaposition entre la sexualité et la
piété ou la croyance religieuse dans ses
relations avec les filles de joie marie
victorin a l'impression de marcher dans
les pas du christ
voyez l'attitude du christ vis-à-vis de
madeleine n'est-ce pas tout l'idée de la
transposition des ardeurs du sexe au
domaine spirituel que cette étonnante
parole il lui sera beaucoup pardonné
parce qu'elle a beaucoup aimé cuba aura
finalement été un monde rêvé pour marie
victorin qui cherche constamment à
réconcilier la sexualité et la religion
pourquoi une femme pure à qui la nature
créée par dessus confère une minutes
d'extase ne remercierai t'elle pas de
jeu auteur de toutes les joies
il ne trace rethel pas à ce moment sur
la porte du temple intime un minuscule
signe de croix
[Musique]
marie-victorin qui a voyagé autour du
monde se trouvent souvent aux états unis
ou bien entretient des rapports étroits
avec les naturalistes de washington de
boston ou new york
ici aussi la sous-tendent cèdent la
place aux costumes et à la cravate ils
descendent parfois à l'hôtel taf au
coeur de manhattan
c'est dans cet hôtel qu un soir une
femme à l'accent russe frappe à la porte
de sa chambre
la russe avait l'air si décidé que je
juge est préférable de ne pas la
contrarier
certes je connaissais par les livres
quel rôle joue aujourd'hui le président
du cal il y a une sensation
indéfinissable demi physique les demies
psychique qui s'ajoute aux autres a
serré entre ses cuisses une tête de
femme en mouvement rythmique aussi
d'éjaculation ne fut elle pas longue à
venir
bien que la présence de cette femme à
cause surtout des circonstances
numéro 6 est aucunement la lecture de
ces événements provoquent chez marcel un
violent rêves érotiques
durant la nuit qui a suivi votre
confidence j'ai rêvé que je me masturbe
est fortement en appuyant sur la vive
avec un bloc de marbre qui n'était autre
que la statue de la sainte vierge à
partir de 39
il ya un paquet franchi du côté de marie
victorin alors que lui ne reste plus
dans cette connaissance on va dire
surtout théorique ni va s'engager dans
la connaissance du corps des femmes
réelles mais elle leur sert gauvreau on
peut pas imaginer qu'il ya plus aussi
faire de telle aventure
elle est à montréal n'est pas quelque
part cachée à cuba une femme qui se
paierait des amants comme ça c'est
inimaginable ça ferait scandale dès que
ça se saurait toute la correspondance
témoigne de leur volonté de demeurer
chasse mais le frère marie-victorin
entraîne éventuellement marcel sur voies
nouvelles
avec une question qui la met au défi
croyez vous qu'une personne lui même a
le droit de prendre des moyens
nécessaires pour se procurer le sperme
nécessaires à l'observation
qu'en pense matériaux logique
je ne vois aucune objection à observer
du sperme vivent chacun fera ensuite à
moux choisi le récit de ce dimanche
passé ensemble de 18 janvier 1942
ce jour là sans penser à mal et sans
aucun péché votre petite fille marcelle
est devenue une femme
je ne pourrai jamais vous remercier
assez d'avoir opéré cette métamorphose
je ne pourrai jamais oublier que j'ai
senti contre moi le battement précipité
de votre chère à l'ancien
j'ai trouvé dans la connaissance directe
de la chaire masculine un intérêt
inexprimable ce fut le dernier voile
l'avant-dernier voile qui tombaient
entre nous je continue de vous aimer
comme avant
de la plus pure affection la mort de
marie victorin dans un accident voiture
en 1944 met fin à cette relation avant
publiée lot comme celle-là ce qu'il ya
toujours un d'autres j'ai eu beaucoup de
doutes parce que je pense qu'on vit
actuellement dans une société que père
du nord qui totalement déconnectée de la
complexité du monde équipe à réaction
sur réagit à des événements en voulant
effacer tout ce qui paraît pas propre
cette étrange aventure vécue entre la
peur du péché et un désir brûlant
d'émancipation révèle l'esprit
fondamentalement libre toit des grands
québécois du 20e siècle et le clergé au
courant là que ça va sortir qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent de cette publication les
frères des écoles chrétiennes ont
exprimé des réserves face au projet de
publication des historiennes gingras
maison ici de ne pas s'y opposer
conservateur qui a aucun scandale c'est
un signe des temps
en effet les temps changent et merci
beaucoup lieu au nom de toute l'équipe
merci d'avoir été là on espère que vous
avez apprécié les reportages de ce soir
est l'émission partir au large pour les
deux prochaines semaines le temps des
jeux olympiques on se retrouve donc le
1er mars pour une autre enquête
[Musique]